Guten Abend, mein Name ist Senepelei Filik.
Ich bin hier die Dienstabende Erzin und stelle Ihnen ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Krankengeschichte.
Aber so erst möchte ich wissen, wie Sie heißen.
Ich heiße Thomas Weber.
Könnten Sie Ihre Vor- und Nachname mischnibbern?
Thomas, T-H-O-M-A-S und Weber, W-E-B-E-R.
Herr Weber, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 59 Jahre alt.
59 Jahre alt. Wann sind Sie geboren?
Am 1.7.65.
75 oder 60?
65.
60.
Also 9965.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,83.
Wie viel wiegen Sie zurzeit?
Ich wiege so 74 Kilo.
Okay Herr Weber, was kann ich für Sie tun?
Was für mich, weil dann haben Sie?
Ich habe solche Schmerzen, die immer schlimmer werden im Bauch, so oben.
Das wird immer mehr.
Es hat sich in den letzten Wochen sehr verschlechtert.
Jetzt habe ich ständig Durchfälle.
Nachts muss ich schwitzen.
Mir ist schlecht.
Ich habe das Gefühl, ich bin überhaupt nicht gut drauf.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Schmerzen?
Das hat angefangen, war das schon vor einem Vierteljahr.
Dann habe ich gedacht, man kann ja mal Bauchschmerzen haben.
Aber in den letzten Wochen, ich würde sagen 2-3 Wochen,
ist das immer schlimmer geworden.
Jetzt kann ich es nicht mehr gut aushalten.
Sind diese Schmerzen langsam oder plötzlich aufgetreten?
Das fing langsam an, würde ich sagen.
Könntest du mir beschreiben, wie ist diese Schmerzen?
Genau, ist er dumpfer, siehende, stehende oder krampfartig?
Du würde es nicht nennen, vielleicht so ein Ziehen.
Es geht um den ganzen Bauch hier oben rundherum.
Können Sie sich einen Auflöser erinneren?
Ich kann mich nicht erinnern.
Mit einem Mal fing das an.
Es fing langsam an, erst waren die Schmerzen nicht so doll.
Aber jetzt sind sie langsam so krass, dass ich das nicht mehr ignorieren konnte.
Ich traue diese Schmerzen so hin.
Ja, das geht bis in den Rücken rein.
Es geht also so ganz rundherum, um meinen ganzen Bauch herum.
Sind diese Schmerzen dauerhaft da oder gehen sie manchmal weg?
Eigentlich merke ich die schon ständig.
Wenn ich schlafe, dann merke ich das nicht mehr.
Wie stark sind Ihre Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzkala?
Wobei eines ist sehr leicht und die anderen sehr stark.
Das sind schon sehr stark.
Sie sind schon richtig doll.
Vielleicht sind sie sehr stark.
Sie sind bei 7 oder 8, würde ich sagen.
Gibt es etwas, dass die Schmerzen verschlechtert oder verbessert?
Verlechtert hat sich vor allem im Laufe der Zeit.
Sonst könnte ich nicht sagen, womit es zusammenhängt.
Ich weiß nicht.
Sind Ihre Schmerzen von etwas abhängig, z.B. Nahrungsaufnahme?
Eigentlich tut es immer weh.
Sie haben gesagt, auch leider haben Sie auch durchgefahren.
Zwei bis drei Mal am Tag, dann rauscht das nur so durch.
Vielleicht haben Sie auch durchgefahren?
Das ist jetzt schon die letzten zwei Wochen.
Vorher war das schon mal, aber nicht so intensiv.
Aber so richtig heftig ist es auch seit zwei, drei Wochen.
Wie sieht der Stuhl aus?
Das sieht ganz komisch aus.
Das sieht ganz hell aus.
Haben Sie bemerkt, dass es in Ihrer Stuhl Blut gibt?
Nein, aber so genau habe ich jetzt auch nicht geguckt.
Aber ich glaube nicht, dass da Blut drin war.
Also rot war das nicht.
Haben Sie noch weitere Beschwerden,
Durchfall und Bauchschmerzen?
Mir ist schlecht, ich habe eigentlich auch jetzt keinen Appetit.
Ich habe auch ordentlich abgenommen, meine Hosen schlackern alle.
Sonst habe ich deutlich mehr gewogen, ich habe jetzt acht Kilo abgenommen.
Ach, acht Kilo.
Ihnen war ich im Zeitraum?
Ja, so in zwei, drei Monaten, würde ich sagen.
Haben Sie schon mal Erbrochen?
Nein, übergeben muss ich mich eigentlich nicht.
Aber wie gesagt, ich habe keinen Appetit.
Und ja, dann wäre ich ständig so ein bisschen schlecht.
Okay, haben Sie Fieber oder Schutteilfrost?
Nein, also mich, dass ich wüsste.
Ich schwitze zwar in der Nacht, aber ich glaube nicht, dass ich Fieber habe.
Also ich fühle mich nicht so heiß oder fieberig an.
Und Schutteilfrost habe ich auch nicht.
Okay, sind Ihnen schwindelig oder schwarz vor der Augen?
Ob mir schwindelig ist, schwindelig.
Würde ich nicht sagen, nee, das sind nur diese heftigen krassen Bauchschmerzen.
Okay, schlafen Sie gut?
Na ja, also nicht wirklich.
Wie gesagt, bis ich erst mal einschlafe, weil mir der Bauchhalt wehtut.
Haben Sie Probleme mit Wasserlassen?
Ja, Probleme habe ich da eigentlich nicht.
Aber da ist mir etwas aufgefallen in letzter Zeit.
Dass der Urin, dass das so, dass das ganz dunkel aussieht, das ist mir aufgefallen.
Haben Sie Brennen oder Schmerzen beim Wasserlassen?
Nein, eigentlich nicht, Gott sei Dank.
Aber ich trinke eigentlich auch ganz viel.
Haben Sie Hautfarbeveränderung bemerkt?
Also nicht, dass ich wüsste, dass ich habe keine Pickel, kein Ausschlag.
Nee, ich wüsste nicht, dass ich Hautveränderung habe.
Okay, gehen Sie regelmäßig Ihre Yrologen zur Kontrolle?
Na ja, so ganz regelmäßig bin ich es ja nicht.
Ich bin ja vielleicht zuletzt vor 50 Jahren oder 6 Jahren gewesen.
Das ist schon eine Weile her.
Okay.
So, Herr Weber, jetzt möchte ich über Ihre Vorerkrankungen etwas wissen.
Leiden Sie an irgendwelche Vorerkrankungen?
Ich war immer kerngesund, ich habe nie irgendetwas gehabt.
Also, was soll man da für Vorerkrankungen haben?
Nein, ich habe nur jetzt Bauchschmerzen.
Okay.
wurden Sie schon mal operiert oder waren Sie schon mal im Krankenhaus?
Ja, ich war tatsächlich mal im Krankenhaus, aber schon lange her.
Das ist 25 Jahre her, da hatte ich einen Autounfall.
Da habe ich mir das Bein gebrochen und das musste gerichtet werden.
Da habe ich meine Weile im Krankenhaus gelegen.
Ist diese Beinbruch operativ behandelt oder?
Ja, da haben die irgendwie so Klatten und Schrauben reingedreht
und die mussten dann auch nachher wieder rausgedreht werden.
Aber das ist eigentlich gut zusammengehalten, da habe ich eigentlich hinterher auch keine Schwierigkeiten gehabt.
Okay, super.
Nehmen Sie Regen, messe ich mir die Kommentare ein oder bei Bedarf?
Ich nehme eigentlich nie irgendwas.
Aber ich gehe auch wirklich nicht so oft zum Arzt.
Ich bin nicht nur hier, weil ich diese heftigen Schmerzen habe.
Okay, sind Sie allergisch gegen etwas oder haben Sie Unverträglichkeiten?
Nein, ich kann alles essen und trinken.
Keine Allergie.
Okay, jetzt möchte ich über Ihre Genussmittelgewohnheiten etwas erfahren.
Trauchen Sie?
Ja, ich rauch klar.
Ein Päckchen am Tag brauche ich schon.
Wie viele Jahre trauchen Sie?
Das hat schon angefangen, als ich so 16, 17 war, da habe ich angefangen zu rauchen.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, ich trinke ich über jeden Tag im Bier abends oder auch schon tagsüber.
Ich habe meine Arbeit verloren und da trinke ich auch schon tagsüber schon mal eine Plasche Bier.
Okay.
Haben Sie Erfahrung mit Drogen?
Nein, mit Drogen habe ich keine Erfahrung.
Ich habe schon eher mein Bier mehr oder auch mein Schnaps oder so.
Ja, das muss schon, ja.
Aber Drogen, da habe ich nichts mit im Sinn.
So Herr Weber, als nächstes möchte ich über Ihre Familien etwas fragen.
Leiden Ihre Eltern irgendwelche Erkrankungen und leben Sie noch?
Also mein Vater lebt nicht mehr, der hatte Darmkrebs.
Der ist gestorben und meine Mutter ist Topfit, die ist 84 Jahre alt, aber der geht da nicht gut.
Wie alt war Ihre Mutter noch mal?
Die ist jetzt 84.
Und Sie ist gesund?
Die ist fit, ja.
Arbeiten Sie seit nichts, oder?
Nein, ich bin schon seit fünf Jahren arbeitslos.
Mein Alter kriegt man natürlich auch nicht mehr so leicht.
Was machen Sie vorher als Berufli?
Was haben Sie gemacht?
Ich habe als Drucker gearbeitet, aber das braucht man heute überhaupt nicht mehr.
Das ist alles heute mit Computern und da braucht man keine Drucker mehr.
Okay, sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin geschieden.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, eine Tochter, aber die hat dann auch bei Ihrer Mutter gelebt und die ist nicht bei mir.
Ist sie gesund?
Ja, so viel ich weiß, geht sehr gut, ja.
Okay, Herr Weber, ich glaube, dass alle meine wichtige Fragen schon gestattet.
Möchtest Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Ja, ich will jetzt natürlich schon ganz gerne wissen, dass man gegen diese Bauchschmerzen tun kann,
woher es kommt und was man dagegen machen kann.
Ja, so Herr Weber, jetzt kann ich nicht etwas genaueres sagen,
aber wir werden Sie körperlich untersuchen und ein paar Labor-Untersuchungen durchführen,
eine Abdominal-Ultraschall-Anforderung, dann kann ich Ihnen etwas genaueres sagen.
Aber ich habe einen Verdacht, dass Sie Probleme mit Ihrem Darm haben.
Mit dem Darm?
Vielleicht eine Darm entzündet.
Ja, das kommt mir auch so vor, weil ich ständig diesen Durchfall habe und weil mir der Bauch so weh tut.
Okay, gut.
Ich bitte Sie, um jetzt einen Platz im Wartezimmer zu nehmen, dann rufe ich Sie wieder auf.
Oh ja, gut, dann setz ich mich rüber, danke schön.
Danke mir auch.
Haben Sie eine Reise nach einer asiatischen Land unternommen?
Nein, das kann ich mir noch gar nicht leisten, ich war gar nicht unterwegs.
Nein, nein, ich bin nur zu Hause gewesen.
Und könnte es sein, dass Sie etwas Verdorbenes gegessen haben?
Nein, ich habe so wenig gegessen und das geht ja auch schon so lange, aber ich ist nix was Schlechtes.
Nee, nee, das glaube ich nicht.
Danke.
Ich denke, keine Reben haben gelegene.
Ja, offensichtlich, möchte niemand etwas wissen.
Ich habe uns eine Belegung gelegt.
Das war eingeblendet, ja, genau.
Nicht mehr als sonst.
Früher habe ich jetzt auch, aber nicht besonders viel.
Ihr könntet mir anfangen.
Ein paar Minuten noch, möchte ich.
Okay, ja, wir wollen nicht hetzen.
Sie hat ja auch drei Minuten weniger gebraucht.
Müssen Sie danach auf die Toilette gehen?
Manchmal, aber eigentlich nur, wenn ich viel Bier getrunken habe, aber sonst noch.
Also ich kann auch manchmal durchschlafen.
Okay.
Hautverfärbung, gibt es gefragt, oder?
Welche Verfärbung?
Hautveränderung.
Hat sie gefragt, ja, aber da wusste er natürlich auch nicht, was sie meint.
Beweis, die Kollegen haben wir, aber keine Verfärbung.
Keine weiteren Fragen, ne?
Ja, gut, dann, also es war ja auch sehr vollständig.
Wie viele Schnapsgläser trinken Sie?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Ja, sie hat nicht weiter nachgefragt nach dem Alkoholkonsum.
Also er trinkt mehrere Flaschen Bier am Tag und gelegentlich Schnaps zusätzlich.
Das ist also schon nicht unerheblich, ja.
Wie viele Jahre?
Wie viele Jahre? Schon lange.
Schon lange.
Also wenigstens die letzten fünf Jahre, wenn nicht länger.
Okay, danke.
Könnte wir anfangen?
Ja.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, aber ja.
Guten Abend Frau Wiechmann.
Ich möchte heute einen, ich möchte, nein, ich habe einen neuen Patient,
ich habe einen neuen Patientin, den Ihnen vorstellen möchte.
Ja, sehr gut, okay.
Haben Sie seit dafür?
Ja, natürlich.
Es handelt sich um Herrn Thomas Weber.
Er ist 59 Jahre alt, 1,83 m groß und 74 kg schwer.
Er stellte sich vor wegen seit drei bis vier Wochen bestehende,
er stellte sich vor wegen Oberbauschmerzen.
Die Schmerzen sind drei bis vier Wochen schlechter geworden.
Diese Schmerzen sind ungefähr vor acht Monaten langsam aufgetreten.
Die Schmerzen haben siehende Charakter und strahlen in den Brücken auch die ganze Bauch.
Die Schmerzinkonstant liegt bei sieben bis acht von zehn auf einer Schmerzskala.
Der Zweite Klagge ist auch über vier, zwei bis drei Mal täglich.
Der Stuhl sieht hell und reich aus.
Die Bescheverdernsein begleitet von Mauser und Müdigkeit.
Die Vegetativanamnese ergab eine Inappetenz und Gewichtsabnahme von acht Kilogramm in drei bis zwei Monaten.
Die Schmerzen sind in Somnä, eine dunkle Urin.
Die Vorerkrankungen sind unauffällig, aber vor 25 Jahren habe er ein Femmophraktur.
Er ist in Folge eines Autounfalls, die mit operativ behandelt worden sei.
Er nehme keine Medikamente regelmäßig ein.
Bei ihm ist keine Allergien und Unverträglichkeiten bekannt.
Er ist Raucher mit 17 Lebensjahr und seitdem rauche ich ein Packung Zigaretten pro Tag.
Alkoholkonsum mit täglich, mehrere Fleischbier oder Schnapsbeacht,
Struckenkonsum mit den Verneinen, in der Familie Annamnese sein.
Eine Kolonkarstin um beim Vater, die voran gestorben sei und bekannt und ihre Mutter sei gesund.
Seine Mutter sei gesund.
Er war seit fünf Jahren arbeitslos, aber zuvor er als Drucker gearbeitet.
Er sei geschieden und habe eine gesunde Tochter, die bei ihrem Mutter lebt.
Sehr gut.
Die an amnestischen Angaben deuten am ehesten auf eine Pankreatitis hin.
Was könnte das Differenzialdiagnose noch sein?
Als Differenzialdiagnose kommen chronische, entsündliche Darmerkrankungen, morbus crone und ulcerativ colitis.
Alkohol bedingt die Hepatopathy.
Was machen Sie direkt noch durch mit den Patienten?
Ich würde gerne erst eine Kölperlihe unter Suchung durchführen.
Worauf achten Sie bei der körperlichen Untersuchung?
Bei der Inspektion kann ich darauf achten, ob die Patientin Hautfallbeveränderung hat.
Besonders in der Siklera.
Bei der Pallpation taste ich den Bauch, ob er Druckdolenz oder Abwehrspannung hat.
Ich höre die Darmgeräusche ab.
Dann kann ich eine Brut abnehmen und auch Rimprobe und Sturmprobe abnehmen.
Sehr gut. Was lassen Sie labortechnisch an Brut werden und bestimmen?
Ich kann ein kleines Blutbild antworten.
Ich habe zusätzlich Entstündungsparameter CRPBSG, Amylase und Lipasewerte, Transaminase, auch Bilirubin.
Sehr gut.
Was wäre als nächstes Untersuchungsschema fertig?
Ich kann eine Sonografie durchführen.
Da würden Sie wahrscheinlich schon sehen, ob man am Pankreas Veränderungen sieht, ob man der Entzündungszeichen sieht.
Dann halten Sie mich auf dem Laufenden.
Was machen Sie mit den Patienten, wenn Sie sich das bestätigen?
Der hat eine Pankreatitis. Was empfehlen Sie dem Patienten?
Was machen wir mit ihm dann?
Ich empfehle den Patienten, als die Patientin, stationär aufnehmen.
Ausreichende Flüssigkeitszufuhr, Anforderungen.
Alkohol und Nikotinkarren empfehlen.
Schmerztherapie beginnen.
Sehr gut.
Eine Ernährungsumstellung ist auch sehr wichtig.
Was muss er kriegen?
Wenn sich ein Patient fettiger ist, dann würde ich sagen, schauen Sie, wie es dem Patienten weitergeht.
Dann halten Sie mich auf dem Laufenden.
Ich bin gespannt, ob Sie sich das bestätigen.
Gut, dann war es.
Ich fand die Präsentation ausgezeichnet.
Sie haben auch sehr zügig gefragt.
Sie waren in dem Ananasenbereich sehr schnell.
Sie haben sehr straight durchgefragt.
Sie haben auch nicht Dinge gefragt, die abwege.
Es wurde unmächtig geworden.
Er war selbst überstammt.
Sie haben nicht nach Herz stolpern.
Sie haben sich sehr gezielt in die Richtung gefragt.
Sie sind gut eingegangen auf die Dinge, die er schon gesagt hat.
Sie waren sehr aufmerksam.
Er hat gesagt, dass er arbeitslos ist.
Sie haben gesagt, sie sind jetzt arbeitslos.
Was haben Sie denn früher gemacht?
Sie haben sich gemerkt, was man schon vorher gesagt hat.
Sie haben wirklich toll gemacht.
Sie haben dann auch eine sehr konsequente Darstellung gegenüber Ihrer Oberärztin gemacht.
Das war sehr kompakt.
Aber ich würde sagen vollständig.
Es ist eine winzige sprachliche Sache.
Es ist keine Allergien oder Unvertretlichkeiten bekannt.
Man muss einfach das plural.
Sie sind keine Allergien und Unvertretlichkeiten bekannt.
Ich habe auch vermerkt.
Sie haben vermutlich falsch notiert.
Sie haben gesagt, seit acht Monaten.
Sie haben auf den richtigen Zug aufgestiegen.
Sie haben genau erkannt, worum es geht.
Aber es kommt immer dieses schöne Stichwort.
Wenn der Patient sagt, die Schmerzen gehen so rundherum.
Er hat Oberbauchschmerzen und strahlt in den Rücken.
Da könnte man sich nicht mehr überlegen.
Aber es ist ein typisches Ding für die Pankreatitis.
Wenn Sie das in der Frage und Präsentation erwähnen.
Das wäre schick.
Sie haben vollständig die Diagnose-Schritte.
Sie achten bei der Untersuchung.
Das haben Sie alles sehr gut geschildert.
Das ist eine sehr gute Frage.
Sie haben gesagt, die Vorerkrankungen seien unauffällig.
Entweder man hat Vorerkrankungen oder man hat keine.
Den Patient sind keine Vorerkrankungen bekannt.
Das war übrigens auch auffällig.
Ich habe das sehr beklagt.
Ich habe das auch aufgestellt.
Regieren Sie einen Koellent Glory.
When a person treated an кабos,
was sagt der Patient?
Ich gebe davon wissen.
Sie haben das sehr durchgängig gemacht.
Die Vorerkrankungen seien unaufgängig.
Ganz ähnlichgetic.
Sie haben auch nicht so ein Euro offencediet doorhare.
Vorerkrankung sei unaufwählig. Es sei, oder nee, da haben sie tatsächlich, es ist
keine Allergenüse kann, aber bei den, bei der Familienanamnise haben sie das auch
nochmal, der Vater sei an Darmkrebs verstorben. Sie haben das also wirklich
sehr, sehr durchgängig gemacht und ja, ich hoffe, Ihre Prüfer würdigen diese
sprachlichen Finesse, weil es nämlich schwierig ist. Viele Deutsche können es
nicht so gut. Ja, die Deutschen haben es nicht so mit dem, mit dieser
konjunktivischen Form und wenige benutzen das so so einwandfrei. Haben Sie super
gemacht. Ja, also ich würde sagen, Sie haben, auch mehr, was habe ich hier noch?
Ja, das waren nur so Zusatzfragen, die in der Prüfung dann noch gestellt wurden,
aber das haben sie sehr schön gemacht. Es ist übrigens ein Düsseldorfer Fall.
Dr. Gündes kennt ihn natürlich. Ja, ich habe nicht. Bei uns gibt es auch in
Rödingen. Gibt es auch so einen Fall. Das ist ja gut. Ja, ich glaube, die
nehmen sich alle nichts die Prüfung. Ja, also, was inhaltlich kommt, das ist
schon sehr, sehr ähnlich, wobei es eben auffällig ist, dass es in Düsseldorf
glaube ich überhaupt keinen Trauma gibt und bei den anderen gibt es zum Teil auch
Trauma-Patienten, aber das ist glaube ich auch der einzige Unterschied.
Gut, ja, also ich fand es super, hat mir gut gefallen.